okay folks we'll get started so today's
talk is about productivity and obviously
since Microsoft has productivity talks
and we've been right productivity tools
and being writing software for decades
then we really should know how to do
productivity on software and we used to
there's a great book called Microsoft
secrets and it was written in in
nineteen in the 90s and it was just when
Microsoft was sort of moving into server
software and it sort of tells the
philosophy at that time it was very much
what you see now in San Francisco which
is the old work hard trusty engineer at
that time was called PC hacking
methodology which is now agile you have
high pay and then assume burn out so
basically burn the people out very alpha
methodology you know overnight bug
bashes all of those things attitude
change really around about the release
of 2000 and Windows XP and these were
sort of horrendously difficult releases
they sort of were supposed to be out in
about 98 they're all very late and then
Windows XP was supposed to be released
the same time as Windows 2000 and what
happened was that it just stressed
everyone to get to get this whole thing
released and after it was released there
was a sort of massive turnover of people
there's a great phrase that was used and
there hopefully they were because of
this this was just before the dot-com
crash so and these were people who were
actually very talented and they really
liked what they were doing but you know
they started working on 2000 and they
had children and they left and they had
teenagers and they didn't quite see the
two between so and this is a lot of
institutional knowledge was lost at that
time and really they realized the
limitations on this trusty engineer and
so we went towards processes and we had
the big security issues and that was the
killer for the circuit for the
trustingly engineers and so and really
before this that's sort of how to do
increased productivity was just a shout
louder of people and they realized they
had to stop people working weekends they
had to start to move to a different
system and then like anything else where
the you know the pendulum theory was it
was too much trusty engineer and then we
went far too much to processes which
tilt aboard everyone to death when they
were doing development and we go to
where we are today and we have
continuous deployment and continuous
deployment the idea is is the developer
sit in his office they write code they
send the code to the to the users they
get immediate feedback from the users
and this is a great way of doing things
because they have this great synergy
with understanding how their software
works and they are responsible for
ensuring the feature works their
features works on the customer site
obviously they're also responsible for
making sure it's secure oh and then this
privacy oh it has to be compliant with
everything as well and it's going to run
on platforms we like your Windows and
Mac and it's gotta go run on Android and
iOS and it's gonna work on all of these
things oh and don't break legacy don't
break what's happened in the past and
we're asking developers we don't want
developers to just sit in their office
and writing because they're gonna
reinvent the wheel what we want them to
do is to use software that already
exists and we want them to be more
efficient in using that software and
incorporate that software into their
software and also that we want other
people to use their software so this is
great the engineers can now just invoke
other people's software uses their own
except for the fact is if that software
has security issues and you've just
inherited those security issues into
your new into your product so not only
do you have to be responsible for all
these other factors you have to inherit
those factors from everywhere else and
then you become responsible so when we
then say what do we want the engineer to
be and how do we want the engineer to be
more productive we really struggle to
understand what does that mean and and
then it depends very context-specific
if you're writing the kernel we do want
you you're not going to inherit anyone
else the software we want you to be
sitting in your office and typing if
you're working on something which is
very high up in the stack then you want
not only people to use your software to
use other people's software so we want
documentation we want an awful lot of
other things so when we then say well
you know what is an engineer today and
how do we measure it and then how do we
make them more productive we you know
we're struggling with that but
thankfully we have the answer and our
speakers today are going to give us the
answer so the first speakers of Gao have
said they are going to be controversial
so I hope they live up to their
reputation of looking at from a high
level of you one of the things is about
productivity is productivity you know
from a systems perspective productivity
can induce stress so so peak car's
looking at it from the customers
perspective and they're saying that our
tools actually generate an awful lot of
stress to them they generate emails they
generously a lot of things so there's
work going on to look at the impact of
stress David and Gurkhas is going to
look at developer satisfaction in the
air in the old days it was like well
they burn out they leave now we tend to
think and happy engineers are more
productive and Peggy's done a lot of
work on that and then we've got Brian is
going to talk about how they're trying
to do in fact we've got a nice thing at
the end whereby Brian's going to talk
about how they are trying to understand
development productivity and then Kim is
going to give us a talk to say why it's
impossible to understand developer
productivity so the way we're gonna do
the talks measure okay
don't start arguing this early so the
way we'll do each of the things is that
the speakers will talk and then it will
do the QA at the end of each session and
we the chairs are all knowledgeable in
their areas with you know lucky to have
Peggy give us the time to come along to
do it so let's start often we can
introduce the speakers good morning
everybody it's just working great so I
have the pleasure of introducing two
luminaries in the field of
human-computer interaction both of whom
come from psychology and work at the
intersection of psychology and computer
science and who are experts in the human
experience with technology so first we
have Yvonne Rogers who's the director of
the interactions Center at UCL so
University College London who is a
fellow of the ACM who is also was
elected to the sig Chi Academy which is
a great honor in our field and who is
the co-author of the probably I guess
the best-selling HCI textbook in the
world I think it's now sold 200,000
copies and 50 dish more than that okay
so that's super impressive and done lots
of work looking at human experience in
the workplace and and in the home and
and just about everywhere else you can
imagine
and then we have Steve Whitaker who is a
professor at UC Santa Cruz in the
computational media department now also
a background in psychology also fellow
of the ACM also a member of the Sigma
Chi Academy and the winner of the
Lifetime Achievement Award at a very
tender age which is quite impressive as
well and he
[Laughter]
he and over who's here have also written
a book on managing digital stuff so a
lot of work in the kind of personal
information management area but I just
want before I turn over to them I just
want to say a little bit more about the
career trajectories because I've learned
a lot about this over the last couple of
evenings down the bar so Yvonne actually
started her first job was in the ladies
underwear department at British home
stores and became an expert in stacking
lady's knickers we call lady's
Underpants knickers in London and became
developed her organizational skills and
also social skills trying to manage the
ladies who kept upsetting the stacks of
knickers that she was putting together
so I think she that was quite formative
in her later career she also worked on a
kibbutz and in the kitchen dealing with
a lot of chicken carcasses as I
understand for some kind of specialty
that the Israelis love and I think that
explains why she's now a vegetarian
that's Yvonne Steve as an undergraduate
in Cambridge so formative roots there
was a worked on cavity wall insulation
and and spraying stuff into the walls of
people's homes we're gonna get him down
to the Attic that seems like a good
start and also work for the first
Pringles factory is that correct that's
right jacking Pringles in the UK for
sprinkles in the UK stacking Pringles so
so this is some of their more humble
beginnings but the other thing I learned
about Steve last night is that he has a
his grandmother was a gypsy fortune
teller and he has some Romani blind and
he's predicted we're gonna have a very
good workshop today but also he's he's a
you know great to talk about the the
future of work and what we predict for
the future productivity so with that I'm
gonna welcome I think Yvonne first thank
you
[Applause]
thank you every stacking means something
different for me than what is commonly
understood in in this field so we you
know when we talk about the stack we
refer to different kinds of and types of
ladies underwear right so we're going to
do a double act
okay and Steve was away in Australia so
I was given the job of writing the title
and the abstract and so I will talk for
the first part on thinking about
productivity from the organization's
perspective and he will then sort of
take over and think about it from the
individuals perspective and I don't know
if any of you've looked at the images
from the last two days but it seems that
everyone has to have their hand up so I
found one of me you know this is how you
talk to people these days so I will be
looking at quantifying and Steve will be
what we've called quantifying so looking
at from a qualitative perspective and at
the end we will have some provocations
to get a discussion going so I need a
bit of sound now because I thought it's
always good to start with a video and
back in the 50s they used to be
marketing as to how to get people to be
productive at work and this one I wasn't
around in the 50s I have to say but this
one always stuck in my mind because of
the jingle get the sound please can you
increase the sound okay
maybe it's in your browser is your
volume all the way up yes I did
I'm rather good at crosswords companies
that make up too easy
six dollars to see a valuable food rich
in proteins using can you might hear it
crunching oh you better hope I'm - I've
never heard of one grunting no change to
pink and and you got aches and they're
rich in protein have any valuable food
good okay so the the jingle was to go to
work on an egg and I think you know 2010
20 years later the Mars one was a Mars a
day helps you work rest and plays so
there's always been something about
eating before going to work which will
make you more productive so I hope
you've all had your eggs this morning
because we want a very productive
workshop so productivity we take it for
granted that we all know what it means
but it's usually defined as a measure of
efficiency of someone completing a task
and that word efficiency is you know you
are trying to obtain some kind of
results a desired result in terms of a
target and the assumption about whether
you can reach that target is that you
have to be in a good state so you have
to be well-fed had your eggs you have to
be well motivated you have to be
talented you have to be skilled you have
to be a good engineer you can't just you
know take the job and you have to be
healthy and importantly you have to be
suitably rewarded you have to have a
good Hey
and various other kinds of rewards and
if all of these are met then you can be
productive but within the world of work
we're always looking for ways in which
to think about how we can improve
productivity
it's become the holy grail in business
and there are so many self-help books
out there now to help you be more
productive not just at work but also in
your personal lives and so it's an
assumption that we can always do better
and I think you know part of the
workshop here is how can we improve
productivity and so there's been many
attempts to do this and it's the
sticking carrot the the carrot is the
incentives you can get bonuses I know
Microsoft they give you huge bonuses if
you do very well then there's staff
recognition where for many blue collar
workers you can become the Employee of
the Month and feel very proud of that
and have a badge or you know your photo
will appear we also have targets
everyone has targets in my field when I
do my appraisals I have to get my staff
to come up with stretching goals I never
really know why they have to stretch I
don't know why you can't just have goals
but you have to stretch so you have to
stretch yourself to reach those and then
there are lots of interventions that
we've been thinking about improve
productivity of organizations and
sometimes humans are unpredictable
unreliable and the automation you can do
it more more product productively and so
sometimes that takes place but also
we've been looking at how we can use
tracking tools by which to measure how
productive people are and think about
how we can help them and then be many
indices that are evolved over time to
measure efficiency and these are just
the most common ones time on task the
sales per quarter the number of calls
made in a particular time span a day or
an hour the number of hours saved or
dollars saved over time the reduction in
costs success rate and for us in
academics it's the number of papers we
have written to get published or the
number of grants that you can get and a
number of patents and so on so there are
depending on the context of the work
setting we have different types of
indices but one of the things that we
all tend to do
so that we compare these industries with
something else and so this you know
typically spreadsheet sales sheets you
can use these to compare how one
employee has done relative to another
and you can do this for a certain time
periods and you can compare with other
employees and companies and part of this
is that it allows you to track to record
and visualize a groups performance at a
glance and this is very powerful tool
for management so you see these types of
dashboards software dashboards
everywhere where it shows the targets
for certain individuals over months or
quarters and then their actual sales and
you can see at a glance whether they've
exceeded or they've underperformed and
this can be for management but these
tools can also be used for individuals
themselves to motivate them so someone I
know I've changed the names here was
showing me his weekly performance sheet
and he works for an employment agency
where they match companies who want
people to do particular jobs in and it
could be gardening or it could be
indicating industry and each week they
are given this which shows GM that so it
stands for their gross margin which is
the amount of dollars that eat each
specialist and the names at the top have
brought in for the company and then the
number of working that's the number of
matches they've made between the jobs
that have come in and the people they
can find to fill those jobs and he was
very proud to show me how when he first
started he was he's only was able to
bring in for the company $8,000 but as
the week went on his gross margin
increased and there was a particular
month when he got very excited he was
like you know double then began with but
also that he was better performing than
others in his team but they also
increased their performance and as a
result of increasing the gross margin
the company took them on a journey to
Las Vegas and this incentivizes them
even more and so this can be very
powerful as a way of comparing yourself
with what you've done
sleep but also with others so it can
provide positive feedback this type of
spreadsheet performance sheet that makes
employees feel very proud and valued but
we know that it can put pressure on
people to work very long hours
especially when they don't reach those
targets and it brings into question that
this is a you know this sort of
timesheet spreadsheet has been used for
four centuries what will the new
tracking technologies do will they you
know enhance the prose or will they
exaggerate or exacerbate the cons I want
to focus a bit on what new tools there
are out there
and I think what's around the corner and
what people are talking a lot about are
the AI and cyber-physical systems and
these are networks of sensors and a iron
and computers that are embedded into
buildings that enable companies to track
and detect and model more aspects of the
workplace and it can use low energy blue
tooth as well by which to track where
objects are or equipment relative to
others in the room and one place where
they've made inroads in the smart office
where for example workers who don't have
their own office and that's becoming
increasingly common they can book and
select workplaces in advance where
there's a cubicle or an office or a desk
and and so when they come that offices
is there for them but also they can
swipe their access card and their phone
calls will be automatically routed to
that desk and that makes it more
efficient and also they can also
customize the lighting another
environmental aspects to their own
personal preferences so that's kind of a
vision and that starting to happen using
this type of cyber-physical system
within hospitals it's also being started
to be used real time location systems
for tracking equipped
and in in one Hospital this system
called the RTLS saved 10,000 staff hours
annually by enabling staff to locate the
devices they need it could be ultrasonic
various trolleys and x-rays and once
they've located to be able to know when
to maintain and to clean them and so the
usage of equipment was greatly improved
through using this type of
cyber-physical system software so I
think the future of these types of tools
is that they can quantify aspects of the
workplace in terms of equipment but now
it's starting to think about what about
the workers we could put wearables on
them we can track what actions they're
doing and also what outputs so having a
much finer level of granularity and one
of the aspirations from this is to be
able to predict more about their working
patterns so we heard yesterday about
thinking about people's intentions or
their intent how can you predict what
actions they want to do at an interface
when our most productive moments might
be and how might you support that when
might be the best time for you them to
meet someone else is it in the morning
is it in the afternoon and and so on and
when do they when's a good time to have
a break and are they spending too long
being distracted with social media and
so on so there's lots of ways in which
you can think about how you start to
track the individual and optimize the
things that they need to do at certain
times and reduce those behaviors that
might be called slacking and this has
led a number of our business leaders to
be really excited about quantifying the
workforce and in Accenture I don't know
who this person is but it was just this
month we're saying how they're it's you
know nearly 80% of business leaders
think that these tools will help them
grow their businesses transform the
business for agility and efficiency and
help unlock the full potential
of people and they can be used to spot
and improve work patterns to speed time
to market or improve speed of adoption
to change programs with customized
incentives for individuals so there's a
lot of hope and promise for using
cyber-physical systems and AI to improve
productivity even more but the flipside
and this is what I think we need to
think of is it can make employees uneasy
and that it's now you know within the
media being reported as workplace
surveillance and it's increasingly being
perceived to be too controlling and too
invasive and that many forms of this
type of monitoring are are considered to
be you know socially unacceptable it's
invading people's privacy and things
like knowing when someone's gone to the
toilet and for how long and also
analyzing their social media both at
work and outside of work and being able
to eavesdrop on their conversations at
work and also looking at their staff
calendars and how they're being used and
computer usage which has been around for
some time but you can use AI to analyze
the patterns are much more than
previously and so the problem is that as
we increase more opportunities and
ability to to track it can at the same
time make employees more uneasy about
what is being done for and here is a
graph from last year that shows the
least preferred types of workplace
surveillance and up the top is surprise
surprise facial recognition software and
mood monitoring 76% of people who were
asked found this unacceptable then
recording of location where you are
unwearable 67% of people found that
uncomfortable and then monitoring social
media outside of work hours 69% and
they're monitoring keyboard activity was
less at 57% I guess because it's been
around for longer and people are more
used to that but also it's not as
invasive seemingly
and um increased tracking can backfire
and there's a study here saying that
performance stays the same people don't
improve their productivity if they don't
know why they're suddenly being tracked
if there's no explanation it's just
being introduced and that there's no
corresponding rewards for being tracked
so you've got to give employees an
explanation and that they buy into it
and that they get rewarded otherwise
it's not going to make according to this
study a difference and so I'm arguing
and I think everyone in the room would
probably agree that we need to think
about how do we make this kind of
tracking more transparent and
accountable and for people to be able to
accept and see the benefits and so the
employees can see what's being tracked
about them be able to manage it and
where you know if they've had a really
bad day or an off day could they remove
their own data and be able to forget
that day and I also think we should
shift our emphasis from focusing on the
work force or on the individual to the
work place how can we use this new
technology to improve the workplace
and if we do that you know you might be
able to improve productivity that way
rather than focusing on the individual
and then I think we need to think more
about in work enhancement tools in
addition to being able to track and
monitor and measure and one from my
colleagues partner Duncan who works at a
company uses his software called sur
cocoa and it it's been around for many
years now to connect remote workers who
work in these very large international
teams and what it does is it increases
their awareness and connectedness with
others through using this type of
visualization and many of us from CSU
w-will know this is a form of social
translucence you can see at a glance
using icons at which move around where
people are in a virtual office and you
can connect with them and you can move
up and down the virtual floors you can
get colleagues to spontaneously
collaborate
you can search for colleagues you can
you know see whether they're available
to chat you can have meetings and so on
so this is a really nice way of
visualizing and giving everyone
particularly those who are remote a
sense of being connected and wanting to
be there at the work place slack as we
know has grown phenomenally and it's
where work happens and it's a very
lightweight support tool for many
organizations and as I saw yesterday
it's the same as with teams it also
provides a shared workspace and this
morning I was looking at the difference
between teams and slack and you'll be
pleased to know that there are more
people companies now using teams in 13
plus million daily active users then our
our slack slack is getting worried
because teams is taking over so you're
obviously doing something right there in
terms of supporting teams with this type
of software and I'd like to move on to
thinking about not negative surveillance
but positive maybe that's the wrong term
but it just makes you think and
surveillance be a good thing rather than
always being a negative thing and that
we can use these technology they
shouldn't always be seen as evil but
that they optimize the workplace and
that they the people working there buy
into it whether it's cyber physical
systems internet thing machine
intelligence and nice visualizations
that show where people are and how you
can connect with them and that we should
be emphasizing making the workplace safe
efficient comfortable and collaborative
so all of those things rather than
focusing on productivity per se and that
we should design new interventions to
improve workflows intelligent workflows
that fits into the work culture and
finally I just want to finish with a
slide that should nicely move into
Steve's talk which is I think we
shouldn't be always emphasizing
productivity and the productivity you
can come with when people happy at work
so we should be thinking about how do we
design
works places that are harmonious provide
harmonious and holistic are ways to
working and that requires focusing on
the employee experience and that's what
Steve will talk about and how can we
enhance wellness health and safety and
also care about things that they care
about which is the environment and
sustainability and as we heard yesterday
is increasingly important that we
develop ethical and acceptable
interventions and ways of working so I
think at that note I'll hand over to
Steve to be more provocative
[Applause]
okay well thank you very much Yvonne
so yes so what I want to do in my
section the talk is I want to move maybe
from more kind of cultural
organizational to thinking a little bit
more about individuals and I'll talk
both about concepts of productivity our
own attempts with our research trying to
end gender or promote individual
productivity our own failed attempts I
should say and then I'll finish by
talking about employee well-being in the
relationship between that and
productivity measures so as I say I'll
be talking more about individual
perspectives and I'll start off by just
revisiting some of those conceptual and
measurement issues that Yvonne drew
attention to I'll talk about two case
studies from personal informatics where
we've tried to do productivity based
interventions and now come back to some
outstanding issues which bridge the two
talks that we've done today so let's
just come back to definition of
measurement and I think one fundamental
problem is that there are lots of things
in productivity that we can rather
easily measure which may not be
amazingly meaningful so for a given
employee we can look at how much time
they spend on a particular task we can
look at the number of reports they
produce we can look at the number of
lines of code we can even look at the
number of workplace goals that they
generate but basically more is not
always better so I'm not sure if I spent
four and a half hours on this
presentation I'm not sure all of you
would think that that was necessarily a
great and better presentation but at the
same time I'm not sure all of us would
agree on what the definition of a great
presentation is so that's one one clear
problem is how we get good quality
metrics another problem which very
closely bears on the issue of individual
motivation is do we want to use
objective measures or subjective ones
because if we if we use objective
measures they may
not be the way that employees see a
particular situation and if we're trying
to motivate we have to think about what
the individuals perspective is and then
some of these other issues that Yvonne
brought up is there's some very subtle
issues surrounding work-life balance and
I guess Brennan also brings these issues
up in the development context which is
we can't just be focused on the product
itself we need to have some kind of
measure in our divisor here about the
total proportion of the employee's life
that they're actually spending in work
so not good enough to produce amazingly
high-quality product if that's kind of a
70 80 90 hour work week and then I think
there's some other rather difficult
issues so one clear issue is individual
versus team productivity you know I'm
sure all of us have worked on teams with
amazingly successful individuals who
samara they don't seem to contribute a
fantastic amount to our team
productivity a related issue is talk
versus work so if you're a manager you
spend a great deal of time doing email
is that work well probably yes because
without you doing all of that kind of
interstitial stuff your team's not going
to be productive same thing if you're a
collaborative team manager you're trying
to be very responsive to your teammates
questions about work-related tasks
because you're all in it together
but Gloria Mart's work again the more
time you spend in email the less
productive you are both subjectively and
objectively so I think some very tough
conceptual issues that it's not
immediately apparent how we might
actually you know disentangle those
issues and then I think there's this
very general perception you know so I
there's a you know as we're all aware
general backlash against
but productivity too I think if you talk
to the you know person the stree what
they're going to tell you is tech is
actually making us less rather than more
productive now we could talk about the
semantics of that but I think that's the
first that's the first reaction that
many people would bring you if if you're
talking about tech so in terms of you
know at some very kind of very
simplistic high level perspective have
we got where we are in terms of tech
approaches to productivity so obviously
Microsoft a pioneer in terms of task
based approaches
so you think word processing programs
spreadsheet programs so the idea here is
you take a task that can benefit from
automation you know producing high
quality documents for example you
produce some kind of tool and that
provides that's one approach to
productivity phase two of this kind of
approach is you introduce smarts into it
and these can be kind of you know
methods like spellcheck or grammar
checking or increasingly kind of tasks
inferencing so those are things in the
past what I want to talk about more
today is the new approach which is to
focus on trying to model and quotes
optimize a person so you know this is
very obvious this is the IOT Internet of
Things type approach we've got so much
data now about every person what we can
do is we can track all their behaviors
in the workplace what how they spend
their time increasingly as Gloria mark
talked about the other day
we can also use new hardware to track
emotions and stress I'm using those
terms advisedly if people want to
discuss it I'm somewhat of a skeptic
about you know the extent to which that
hardware is actually detecting those
things but that the general approach
here is collect amazingly rich data
about an individual generate models of
them and then given those kind of models
help them to improve and what I want to
talk about today is kind of both whether
that's possible our attempts
to do this with a couple of work two
examples and maybe we can visit the
question about what it means to kind of
improve in this context so two examples
as I say the first example is from a
project that we worked on to help people
better focus in the workplace and the
second example I want to talk about is a
is a well-being example so the first
lesson which I want to flag up to you
which is we can design tools which we
think will enhance productivity they may
not necessarily have the impacts that we
intend so you know everybody I guess a
lot of people here went to gloria marx
excellent keynote the other day so we
all know what this problem is whenever
we use digital devices we suffer from
attention fragmentation so the truly
mind-blowing statistic from Gloria's
work is the median time between
switching between applications is 40
seconds right truly amazing and then
there's a lot of very good work which
has shown that there are costs to doing
this which is if you switch frequently
you can't remember anything about your
primary tasks there's a lot of
interesting research on students which
show frequent tasks switches have lower
grades lower GPA and of course there are
stress implications you multitask a lot
switch tasks a lot then you have this
stress consequences for doing that so
why are people doing this I think you
know again this is completely
self-evident well part of the time it's
completely justified so if I'm doing
research on a in relation to a document
then what I'm doing is I'm moving
between a browser and that target
document very frequently or if I'm
working with colleagues on a particular
product I might be in and out of email
and that document those if you like are
explainable switches but what again
glory marks research suggests which is
very very interesting is about half the
time that we switch between applications
there is no
ask related reason for doing so so a lot
of task switching is optional so one of
the things that we try to do in this
first project is we try to better
understand the reasons why people were
task switching and if you like how
people saw their use of time and then we
tried to devise an intervention which
would kind of help them to kind of
moderate that situation so we did a
bunch of interviews these are with both
office workers and with students so one
of the big problems that people have is
just basically keeping track of time
right so neither of these observations
is going to be amazingly insightful to
you right so here's one person it's very
difficult to be aware of things you dip
into email for 10 minutes but you may be
unaware that half the day is gone if you
keep doing it yes right we're all
totally familiar with this experience
with the browser it's easy to get
absorbed an accumulative aspect you when
you start on one page and then several
links down the road you've wasted an
hour or so
all right so about 38% of people
describe this kind of lost in email
experience at work so what we did in
this first intervention is the
observation is people find it hard to
monitor the use of time
why don't we develop an app which
enhances their awareness of use of time
and then if we do this right we should
this should allow them to allocate time
more systematically to their work goals
okay or makes sense
okay so designers out there do not laugh
okay this is a very very complicated use
of time app right so I'm not really
going to spend a lot time explaining how
it goes but basically what this this is
a unda scible app you load this out you
can't get rid of it off your workspace
and what this shows is for this employee
they're spending most of their time in
it this is over the last 30 minutes
they've spent most of their time in
Acrobat and they've spent a little bit
of their time in Facebook right so this
is always running on your desktop I
emphasize it's underst
miserable so we did an audit of similar
kind of use of time apps and we came up
with these following properties so the
thing needs to be really simple right
because if it's complicated it distracts
and that's an ironic effect it needs to
show recent activities because what we
don't want people to be doing is some
kind of philosophical analysis of their
long-term usage behaviors right so we
don't want this is rescue time if you
know that product right you're not going
to say okay I'm trying to be really
focused but where is my time quite going
right I'll spend you know 23 minutes
analyzing this amazingly complex
visualization it's always on as I say
because you don't want that you want to
be on task you don't want to think oh
should I go out and switch the task you
know use of time app on no it's always
on and the point that Yvonne made if we
want people to be more productive we
don't want to think that this is kind of
like you know a management stalking
horse that can be used to kind of track
what they're doing and you know so this
research is about three years old I mean
you're all aware of kind of what's out
there so a lot of the mobile phone
companies I should emphasize this is a
computer based app but you know Apple
has this now on your phone this is the
Android version and what's really
interesting to me is they're actually
use of time apps but they are being
positioned as well being apps right
because that's kind of how we're
beginning to think about this problem
okay so what did we do
so we basically did a fairly simplistic
intervention we said to people on some
days we'd like you to work with that app
and on other days we just like you to
kind of work normally and we had 61
people use the app about a third of them
were office workers the rest with
students and so here's our basic
intuition that if you have that use of
time app then that should actually
increase the amount of time you spend on
task and fabulous okay so here we have
Green is without meat I'm oranges with
it so what you see is when you have use
of time information drops your email
usage drops you use of the browser drops
use of Facebook right absolutely
fantastic
okay so now let's look at productivity
apps absolutely no difference right and
this isn't what we've done it twice
we've done two separate interventions
the same result both times okay so the
unintended consequence is if you tell
people how using their time they don't
necessarily allocate it more to
productive productivity based apps what
they do is they take that time and they
go offline so product what it seems to
be what seems to be the case is for
these users what productivity is is you
know I pointed those definitional
problems at the beginning it's not the
number of minutes that they spend
working it's the numbers you know it's
some function of the total amount of
time they're spending getting the work
that are expected to do done it's not
what we intended but it might be a good
thing right discuss okay so from a
design perspective what we learnt was
you can provide people with rich data
about what they're doing but it may not
have the anticipated behaviors so you
know again from a design perspective we
need to do more than just provide
dashboard and what I want now to do
which i think is more controversial is
to suggest that if we do actually want
to change people's habits then we need
something that's a more targeted
approach
and this I should also point out that
this if we do want to change people's
habits we have to think about people's
motivations in the way that Yvonne
characterized so I want to just very
quickly talk about some psychological
perspective some psychological
theorizing on how you actually change
people's behavior so there's quite a
substantial literature and there's a
very important theory which is called
implementation intentions which was
introduced by goal Witter
and basically what goal Whitsett says is
if you want to change a particular
behavior you first have to develop a
model of that behavior
which shows which in this case is
productivity so what we first need to do
is we need to understand the
relationship between things that people
do and the outcome which is productivity
we then need to use that model to
identify which of a person's behaviors
are most affecting their productivity
both ways we need to show that to that
person and then we need to encourage
them to engage in behaviors which will
add those behaviors engage in and plan
those behaviors which most impact that
particular outcome so you know let's
imagine subject to these kind of
definitional problems that we know that
productivity is some kind of function of
a person's workload the number of their
unread emails how big their office is we
know that's really important right their
personal mood maybe in a manager's mood
the amount of exercise they got how much
they slept and the number of breaks they
took okay so let's just say that that's
our model because we're gonna instrument
everything so we're gonna be able to do
that okay and so within this kind of
theory what we say is we take that and
for an individual worker because we've
instrumented them we find that the
factor that's having the biggest thing
for that particular individual is not
their office size surprisingly enough
it's the number of breaks they take we
show the use of that model
and what we then encourage them to do is
to calendar in that particular behavior
that's having the biggest impact on
their productivity and this is really
important they have to make a concrete
plan to increase their number of breaks
if that's the thing that's kind of
having the biggest impact or they need
to increase the size of their office if
that's the thing that's having the
biggest impact corner office sometimes
that's really important for productivity
you guys know that okay so unfortunately
we haven't done that intervention in the
context of productivity but we have done
something similar in the context of
well-being and emotion emotion
regulation so I just quit kind of
sidebar so the reason why we've been
doing this work is there's lots of
research which basically shows that
emotion regulation is is of an important
behavior in terms of people's life and
work outcomes so people have really good
emotion regulation strategies show you
know they're more gainfully employed and
they're healthier but really in this
context I'm showing you this example
because they can show you how we can
apply that underlying implementation
intentions model so how does this work
in the context of our emotion regulation
model what we do is two parts of the
system so it's a mobile app and what it
does is it pings you multiple times per
day
it says how are you feeling right you
give a mood score and then it asks you
about a bunch of factors which are
contributing to that mood so it might
say did you eat well did you sleep well
did you exercise and then various
work-related questions and what we find
is that after we've kind of do it done
about two weeks of the of deploying that
set of questions we can get a reasonably
accurate model of what factors are
contributing to their mood so that so
much that's not very novel right what is
novel is the second part of the system
that I want to talk about what we do is
we take that model and then we use it to
recommend to people particular
intervention
behaviors that they can engage in so let
me show you how that works so we have
mood scores for a given person over
different days we can develop a mood
model to make
so here's today what we do is we use
that mood model to make a prediction to
somebody about how they're likely to
feel tomorrow and their day after but
the novel part of the system is this
kind of recommendation component at the
top which is informed by that model
we've built of that person so we know
for this particular individual that how
they feel is influenced by how well
they've eaten and also their social life
so what that green thing up there does
is it's an implicit recommendation to
somebody to try and shed you all those
activities and what this change in the
graph shows is if you shed you all those
activities that how that outcome will
change in other words if you shared your
healthy eating event and a social event
the system will change to show you the
mood boost that you get from that so you
get the idea behind this is we have an
underlying model which is based off data
that we've collected we show the user
what things effect that outcome and we
encourage them to plan particular
behaviors which will actually increase
that target outcome right so it's
motivated because the person can see the
reason why they want to engage in that
behavior have some outcome that's
presumably motivating to them so just
really quickly in the interest of time
just going to whiz through so we've done
various evaluations we've we've
evaluated this particular method three
times and basically for this particular
outcome we can show people have improved
mood and perhaps more importantly they
have better strategies for effectively
changing their mood in other words
they're more informed about the set of
activities which they believe will
actually have a positive influence on
their mood okay so second lesson
it's not necessary if we want to change
people's behavior it's not enough to
just give passively give them feedback
what we want to do or what we need to do
is we need to think about ways to help
them target and schedule specific
behaviors that are going to kind of have
productivity outcomes and the way that
we do that is we use this kind of theory
in which shows people the impact
positive impact of engaging in a
particular behavior which is motivated
by their model and we encourage them to
make a plan to shed you all that
behavior so I'll point out in the
context that well-being app it's
integrated with a calendar which
actually has you kind of put those
things on your schedule okay and the
second point I want to make in the
context of kind of funky AI which we're
all into these days is we could not do
this with a neural nets model because
basically you have to have something
that's kind of explainable and
comprehensible so they can't the
features have to be particular behaviors
which are comprehensible to people
because if people can't actually see
visualize a concrete activity that they
can engage in and plan so it's no not
it's no good having some machine
learning derive feature in this model
because that's not a thing that a person
can plan so this is again an argument
for having these much more user centric
models and I can talk about how we might
actually do that okay so to sum up my
bit two case studies the first one is
given the tools they might do very
sensible things which aren't necessarily
what we planned which brings up the
question like well what are we actually
trying to optimize here the second thing
is if we do actually want to optimize
things and we do want to give more than
kind of like dashboard level information
we need to think about how we can take
what's possible now with these kind of
cyber human models to build something
that a person can understand and they
can see what they personally can do
something about in terms a concrete plan
right so the question I've shown you
this in terms of well-being one question
is you know can we also do this for
productivity okay so I just want before
we come to kind of some you know
provocations are talking so just want to
kind of say here are some things that I
didn't match to get to which our clearly
still totally outstanding you know we
haven't come back to you know we still
have outstanding issues about definition
and management a measurement and these
have kind of quite clearly come up in
the context of this talk you know we
gave people a tool which showed them
about use of time what they did was they
produced their own behaviors which were
closer to trying to optimize work-life
balance and of course there are still
these outstanding questions that you
know we I haven't addressed it all here
which are individual versus team
productivity and work versus talk okay
so then more questions than answers so
let me just kind of come so we can
finish right there but if people want to
begin a conversation then these are some
thoughts that we had in the context of
trying to frame questions that we might
want to talk about more during the day
[Applause]
yeah well I think I think what you want
it so the idea behind the app is not to
tell you what to do every second of the
day it's to basically give you greater
insight into how you're actually using
your time and to better understand the
relationship between your particular
work or life goals and particular
activities that you engage in so the app
isn't telling you what to do notice that
the app just offers up the information
and then you plan how you use your time
but it's very important for the theory
that you don't just say so you know
think about new year's resolutions right
you know most people say I'm gonna drink
less and I'm gonna go out more right
those don't convert those aren't very
good near resolutions in terms of their
efficacy because they're not specific
enough so that's what so basically the
idea behind the model here is it informs
you but you plan what you're doing and
it's not planning every minute of the
day it's planning particular activities
which Ament have implications for your
overall goals
well they're decided they're deciding
what to do right so it's not like the
app says you're going to take more
breaks it's if the app says this is how
you're spending your time make a plan to
change that if you want to change it but
it's important it is importantly commit
to that because you don't commit to that
then you're in there I'm gonna smoke
less type of territory as opposed to
when I go to the pub on Friday nights
I'm gonna try to smoke one for your
cigarette which is more likely to happen
the second
yeah I mean maybe that maybe it's closer
to this type of notion I mean because
that's not committing to any particular
definition of what the job because I
think it could vary for different people
and it may not be the entire population
may not be able to kind of be creative
in a job but at least they should you
know be able to find a job that is you
know subject to some value is it's
rewarding to them so yeah I think
there's a real tension between what you
as an individual can achieve and the
awareness of the things are important to
you and the company you work for and
what they expect from you so if you're
working at you know donald's or
somewhere it's very different than if
you're working in a
an architect's practice where you have
much more freedom but how you do your
work and and how you're valued and how
you're appraised and maybe it goes right
back to the value of the whole thing
about rewards and appraisal and what's
expected of you at work and you know we
need to go maybe even a step further
back than thinking rethinking
productivity
and it might be a question of
granularity here because I mean another
a different way of playing bike where
you just said RB is is that these kind
of things are kind of like monthly these
are more kind of like personal
evaluation type things where's a lot of
the productivity work has been kind of
what are you doing on a daily basis so
it might be interesting just as a
thought exercise think well what would
me time look like for a year right so
what would it mean to kind of have use
of time around kind of maybe more you
know so so to what extent did I do you
know kind of mentoring work to what
extent did I do kind of core project
work to what extent did I do kind of you
know company kind of charitable you know
so so you might imagine you can
dashboard anything right and you can
make anything actionable so I I think I
think it is a question so it might be
that by abstracting you know because I
think Vista I think you're right I be
this kind of micro stuff is not is not
very motivation I mean it's motivational
in one sense right but I think in in the
larger sense if you're thinking about
being a manager and trying to
incentivize employees this kind of stuff
is not really yeah so a point taken
absolutely
yes so I kind of that's one of the nice
things you get about this kind of
implementation intention which is it's
supposed to be that you should be able
to tell the impact of a thing you're
doing now for some an outcome that you
think is important so I think that's
because that relates the question
meaning right because nobody nobody
wants to be toast of that's a waste of
time right
I mean this is I get a lot of this is
already in kind of software productivity
tools because you're just describing
kind of dependencies now but maybe what
you want to do is you might want to
think about not just who is this for
but maybe kind of what what would that
person get from this how important is
this particular thing that I'm doing for
the team in general so there might be
some kind of feedback you could get for
that
so your take your tongue out like a flow
concept some point you have to reflect
on what you've done as to whether you
have had a creative time and maybe these
tools that were suggesting these might
not be these tools but there could be
you know new kinds of reflection tools
on and you can maybe could get you know
like the 360 degree you could do that
for creativity so others could say well
yes that's really creative what you've
done there but it's like how do you
measure those flow or creativity we
don't have tools in a way which we do
for productivity or usability and that's
something that's quite hard to measure
because it's a subjective as to whether
yeah so I mean so certainly me time
might so we all know that interruptions
break flow I think we may not know
exactly what flow is so you could have
these types of tools you know you could
imagine something that was like me time
which was showing and if you had
different kind of reporting structures
associated with those so you could you
could you know maybe it could prompt you
to say you know in a more analytic or
reflective sense you know these these
have been your kind of you know this is
a pattern of your work time during the
day tag that up in terms of you know how
rewarding that felt so then maybe you
could better understand what the
characteristics of those kind of flow
type X you know what characterized those
kind of flow type of experiences because
I think we can get you I think you can
use these types of tools to kind of
overcome that kind of persistent you
know attention fragmentation but it
would be great to better understand you
know just how long that was and you know
what what have been involved what was
the set up for that and maybe I think
the other point we can't lose in all
this is is most people are part of a
team you know I guess that I guess the
team taught yes there's like you know
people spend 82 percent of their time
in teamwork I'm not sure how that's
exactly measured but you know so that
that's the eternal tension here isn't it
I mean it's like I can be in flow but if
you need the answers to you're you know
kind of urgent question right yeah you
know I think that's it but I think we
can instrument better and I think we can
ask questions about maybe meaning you
know what by elevating this from use of
time to kind of meaning or flow I think
we could better understand what it would
take to be in that situation
collecting everything we can
I think that's a really important point
and I started off my talk saying how the
specialy is quite it can be a very
strong motivator and it can be very
rewarding if you see that you you all
your efforts have resulted in you
improving your your performance and then
you can be feel proud and that maybe in
itself sufficient but now that we can't
can collect as you say they're much more
data about people does having that fine
grain you know that granularity actually
you know provide better or increased
productivity relative to how people feel
it because I think you know you do read
although I haven't seen many studies of
just how uneasy people feel it's very
much reported you know in the press that
it's just you know we shouldn't be doing
this or you know how far have we gone
and is it you know do people feel
comfortable that knowing that their
social media their their Facebook posts
are being analyzed by people at work and
that seems to me maybe we've put gone
too far is what why do we need to do
this how is that informing the companies
you know goals and practices and so I
think we do need to have more studies
where we can say well you get you know
you get enough well you get plenty of
data about someone's productivity if
that's still a desirable goal by just
doing this if you go this far then
productivity might actually go down and
people start to resent the fact that
they you know where they're going is
being tracked so I think my point about
cyber-physical systems is that you can
track the workplace the equipment's and
things and that can make you know
people's lives more efficient because
they know where things are but as soon
as you start tracking people
then I think you've you know you've
crossed the line and that's where we
might be thinking about why are we doing
all of this if you want to well I I mean
we
i I don't have an in-principle decision
but basically we design that app against
a rescue time as you know is server
based and they're basically profiling
huge numbers of people so our app was
deliberately designed to be private to
kind of finesse some of these you know
on our you know our other well-being
everything's kind of on the phone
basically but for that that kind of
reason but of course I'm not a
corporation
so I mean I just say the ambiguity point
I think is a really interesting one but
we can't we can do things to kind of
moderate ambiguity we can't remove it
because intrinsically certain new thing
I mean it depends on what you know I'm
not familiar with exactly what you you
know you're kind of workflow er tasks
are if you're doing new stuff that's not
been done before or that involves
technology that's novel you're gonna get
ambiguity right so the best that you can
do under those circumstances is to think
about ways to kind of minimize that make
people aware of the of thats this that
that's the set of operating conditions
as opposed to a more normal situation so
so if some of these spirit floundering
they should know which class of
situation they're in so I'm just saying
it may not be possible to remove
ambiguity but if you if you can
parameterize the situation then you can
at least understand what situation
you're right so these types of a
goal-directed approaches I don't think
they're gonna function amazingly well in
an ambiguous situation because it's
really not clear you know that you can
define the goal or measure the goal
under those circumstances but basically
you know you can certainly see how these
approaches abstractly are basically
trying to have people focus on
particular things that they should be
thinking about doing systematically that
have a direct impact on the thing that
they or everybody is trying to do and
that can kind of that can kind of if not
removed but minimize ambiguity so you
can treat these things literally or you
can treat them more kind of
metaphorically
but you do need to think about what you
do when you have an ambiguous situation
right you've been had your hand out for
ages
hierarchy declared but organizations
were increasingly
response to that I I tend to think about
this problem is the agency problem
control and how much direction I think
we have we have the capability to
Microsoft
I don't know
[Music]
you got a point maybe the word inspect
is the wrong way of thinking about it
and it's more about revealing about
things and the more we can sense and the
more we can reveal about ourselves but
if we haven't reached those our own
personal goals or the company's goals
then we perhaps a revealing too much
about ourselves and that can be
problematic we're people how do you deal
with the fact that you haven't reached
your goals or reach the targets set or
that you are you know the rest of the
team are doing better than you and so
the dealing with disappointment and not
succeeding as well you know is it that
you just need to work harder and we
often think that's the case but maybe
there are other things that are causing
you not to be able to you know to to
achieve what you're thinking or
expecting to do and the more you reveal
about yourself through your emails and
so on the more this could become
magnified and so I think there's a
problem of how much and it goes back to
the point made earlier how much should
we reveal to others about what we're
doing
[Music]
yes but you can see you can see both so
let me let me describe a concrete
behavior which is actually based around
this kind of fear of failure so I did
some work on software productivity now
quite some time ago actually I'll just
mention that it was at Lotus so you know
now I don't need to tell you exactly
when the timeframe was but but basically
one of the things that we saw developers
doing was they would complete their work
related goals but they would not inform
the rest of the team that they completed
and the reason why they did this was
that they were concerned they might have
a stack of goals that they had to
execute if they could get a small goal
done early in the week they could
actually create take the pressure off
themselves and they would then move on
to subsequent goals without telling a
bit anybody else on the team because
basically they wanted to avoid the fact
that they would they might have to say
they'd failed now this is obviously not
team productive right because if
somebody's in you know complete and
important tasks that others are
dependent on and they're not telling
people that that's complete so so you
can see both sides so I'm not saying
let's surveil everybody but you know
basically they're what you want to do is
to create a culture which basically says
you know that it's great if you've got
your objectives done in the time that
you're supposed to have done them but
you know you get 92 percent if you've
not completed but you towers right
because if you don't create that second
culture then
and you've got the problem in which his
people have completed things and then
they're kind of implicitly holding
everybody back because they're being
secretive about those goals so so I
think there are ways and none of this
we're not now talking about tooling
we're talking about ways that we
actually organize or create the culture
that we create around the set of tools
that we have
[Applause]